DON'T KN STAND BY.IDENT IS NOW
OVERE
TO ENT BIDEN.
PRESIDENGYPT.NNI
E FIRE TO BEGIN INO HOUR
OFFICIALS HAVE I THAT S ANOTHEO
HAVE ALSO .
THIES TO A MDE EDE DECISION
CLOSE IN LESS THAN1 . EMPSIZE
THROORTS
AGNS FROHAMAS LSO SHARED  FOR D
HAS SAVE COUNTLESS
CITIZENS, BOTARND
I ASSURE HIM OT SH ISRAEL'S IRO
SYEMENSURE DEND SECURITY IN THE.
O SPOKE WITH P 1 DAYS I SPOKWIT.
O ALSO THANK THE
INCREDIBLE EFFORTS TO TEAM
BRING THIS OUTCOMEHAE
E SEE.
YOU KNOW,
DISCUSSIONS HOUR
LLY.
EGYPT, THE PALESTINIANRITY
AND OTHER MIDDLEAS
COUNTRIES WITH A NG THET WE'VSE
I EXTEND MY SINCERE GRATITUDE TO
I ALS
WHO HAVE PLAYED TICA
ROLE IN THIS.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OTHER PARTIES
IN THE REGION WHO HAVEEEN
ENGAGED IN WORKING TOWARD THE
EN HOSTILITIES.
THES RESULTED
DE OF SO MY
S CHILDREN.
Y SINCER
ALTH, ISRAELI AND
PALESTINIAN WHO HA LD
ESPE F FULL
RECOVERY FOR THES COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEOND WE REMN COT
ASSTNDL SUPPORT FO
WE WILL DO THIL PARTNERSHIP WITI
ORITY, IN A MANNER THA
HAMASSI
RELITARY ARSENAL.
E
ISEL
SAFELY ANDD ENJO
EQUAL MEASURES OF FREEDOM,
ND DEMOCRA
MY ADMINISN LLNUQUIET, RELENTLEC
M MM WORKING TOWARD INE ITY TO
IT.
I WANT TO THYOU ALL.BLU ALL ANA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> SO THERE HE IS,OF THE UNITED.
HE DIDN'T TAKE ANYORTERS
ES BUT H ATEMENT THINKING THERE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVBE
SOT OF GENUINE PEACE
'SNG EASY
BETWEEN THE ISRAELIS ANDHE
PALEIAE EGYPT ANISI
OF EGYPTIND E
SCENES ROLE IN ACHIEVINGHIS FIR
ISRAEL.
HAD ISRAEL'TK TO
ROKERES THEYHEREICANROAN
IS
HAMAILATTINGLY YOU FROM THE
PRESIDENWERE YOU SURPRISED
BY ANYTHIN SAID?
>> I THINKWA IN LINE
WITH THE YOU'VE SEEN
COE LASTAYRESIDENT OVER
EMENT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE T RELO
CONFLICT SINCE INSWERED A FE
FROM REPORTERSBUT THIS IS E
HE'S SPOKEN ABOUT
.
HE ALSO HASN'T SPOKEN PUBLICLY
THE COMMENTS WER
CALIBRATED
HE COMMENDED PRIME MINISTER
NETANYG OFF ON
THIS AGREEMENT
NE RESTOCK ANY I  EIP THAT WAS
ALSOCLEAR WHEN IT CAMEO
THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY, THE
U.S. WOULDPO
WORK TO  HUMD
HERE. THE COUNTRY.E'S A COUPLE
US HAVE ENG TO FIGUROUT IS, IS ,
RELELOMACY SET
THAT'S GOIO FF
YOARD THPRESIDENT
SPECIFICALLY CITE TH.
AT UNDERSCORES THAT,
TWO THIS WILL BE THE WHE
CONTINUE THIS INHEND
OBVIOUSLY T OF THIS IS
DEPEE REOLONE THING TO EYE
ONE CALL WITH ALIS EGYPT, EGYPTT
ROLE JUST LIKE THEY D IN
THTO ANDCH W
THIS OUTCOME.
F CALL WITH
AL-SISI, AT LEAST PUBLICLY THAT
WE'VE SEENINCEE TOOK
HOW THAT RELATIONSHIEVOLVE>> I
TO RESPOND WORDS
FROM T PRESIDE DURING HIS
APPROXIMELUTE EMENT?
>> Reporter:ONG WORDS OF
SUPPORT.
AT
SUHE UNITED STATES.
WE'VE HEARIMMI
AS DAYS AGPRIME EIVED ON THOSE
TOUGH E CALLS FROM PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
OUR FRIEND, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
I THINK THAT'SOI TGO
WELLI THINK THERE WILL BE SO
ISRAE CONCERNS T
THE GONE FOR A
CEASE FIREN. TEDAND KNOW THAT H
THE CAPABILITY AND CAPACITY TO
CONTINUE TO TARGET
IN U BY SIDENT BIDEND.
HE SAID  WIL OURSELVES
AND WORK WITUMANITARIAN RELIEF
TO
THE UNITED STATES NG FOR
HUREHELP
WITH THE REBUILDING.
70,000 PEOPLE T OF THEIR
HOMEINAZA, SO THAT MONEY IS .
THE IMPORTCAVEAT THERETH GTH PE
HERE, SOMETHINTH YOUREGNNVSAWIT
MONEY ISOTTHE HANDS OF HAMAS TO
THEIR WEAPONS.E MONELLHE PALEST.
THE PALESTINIAAUY DOES ATEN
RO
'SO
SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT, BUTHAT'
>> YOU DIDEAR THE PRESIDENT
SAY HE WANTS THA
PARTNEAELIS
AND THE PALESTINIAAUT THEN HDEDO
HA
RICHARD HA JOINING US. KNOWS A .
GI REACT WHEARD FROM T AND
YOUR REACTFIT GOES INTO
EFFECTUPPOSEDLY AT T T.
>> WOLF, IT'Y OME.
WE OBVIOUSLY HOPBUULD BEGIN TO A
CEYTE
T.
HAMAS WIREARM.
HONESTLY I DON'T HAT MA NOT
SE OPPORTUNITYE,T TH STATE HOTN
THIS IMPF THE ISSUES
MIDDLE EAST, ON
ISEWIT
GN AS FAR AS THEREGION.
>>CIPATE TS. ADMINISTRATION,
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WILLINJORT
BEYOND A CEASEE AN PROGRESS
TOWAO-OL SHORT ANSWER
RELATION BEN SIMP A
AUTH
THOBIS HTROL
GASNEPRAE PALESTINIATHY IS AIST
KEEPUSH STON THE ECONOMY,  COVI.
AGAIN, I SIMPLT SETHAT WOULD JUY
Y IC
INITIATIVE.
ISRAEL IS PROBABLYDI NOW
FOATE EDO CALLTINJ EHU
S IS
IF YOU'RE  BLINKEN